hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his so Matteo
di prima sack unday question 2 which is
concerned with human happiness Thomas
Aquinas is going to consider a number of
different candidates for what could be
happiness and one of the sets of things
that that he considers are what we can
call goods of the body and goods of the
soul and this encompasses a wide range
of things these are different from for
example pleasure which he's considering
in article 6 which can be pleasure of
the body or pleasure of the soul here
he's considering things that you might
say make the body or the soul good or
consist in its its life its health
whatever it is that we want to to talk
about as a good state for the body or
the soul and he considers these in
article 5 for the goods of the body and
article 7 for the goods of the soul so
you might say well why is he even
considering happiness in terms of the
body and you know there's some arguments
that he is providing hear arguments
taken from others so he says it would
seem that there's an objection one that
a purse
happiness consists in bodily goods in
any cites scripture here there is no
riches above the the health of the body
right but happiness consists in best so
it would be the health of the body and
from a certain you know framework that
makes a lot of sense he also quotes
Dionysus of pseudo Dionysus on the
divine names that treatise that to be is
better than to live and to live is
better than all that follows but for a
human being being and living the health
of the body is necessary so bodily
health would be what happiness would
consist in as well and then he makes an
argument about causality you know saying
that the the causality the efficient
cause consistent it's flowing into
something so the quasi Allen at the end
consists in drawing the appetite and we
would be looking at what attracts the
desire of all an argument that he made
earlier in this section and he says but
being itself is that which is most
desired of all so man's happiness
consists most of all in things
pertaining to one's being including the
health of the body or its life in that
one he's not saying that that would be
exclusively what happiness would consist
in but he's saying that health would
play a role in that
now Thomas is going to reject that point
of view and it's not surprising that he
would and it's not simply because of a
theological conviction or anything like
that this was a prevalent conception
among ancient philosophers many many of
whom were pagan some of whom were you
know Jews or Christians that the goods
of the body really don't measure up in
relation to the goods of the soul so and
then he also points out is this
interesting argument that you know if
you think about our bodies they're not
really that great in relation to animal
bodies other animals bodies as well but
his answer is that it's impossible for
human happiness to consist in the goods
of the body for two distinct reasons and
these have to do with the ways in which
goods are ordered in relation to each
other so he says if a thing be ordained
or did not err in Latin so you could say
ordered as well to another as its end
its last end cannot consist in the
preservation of that being and he gives
an analogy there between a captain and a
ship and interestingly he's going to say
the captain does not intend as a last
end the preservation of the ship
entrusted to that captain now we often
you know when we know the captain has to
go down with the ship we have this idea
in mind that the captain is primarily
concerned about this vehicle that the
captain is in charge of and the captain
is in charge of it and it is a good
thing to maintain the ship but what's
the point of the ship it's to go from
one place to another it's not just to
sail around for its own sake the ship is
not a living thing you know desiring to
preserve itself for it for its own sake
the way you know you could argue that
our body is to some degree
no the captain's last and and the ship's
last end is to transfer whatever is
being moved from one place to another so
he says the ship is entrusted to the
captain so that he may steer its course
we are like that ourselves in that we're
given over to our will our Faculty of
will or Faculty of choice and our
Faculty of reason so he says that a
human being is ordained as something to
their end so we're not the supreme good
what is the supreme good going to be if
you look ahead in the soma tale oh yeah
it's going to be God so the last end of
a person's reason and will cannot be the
preservation of our being
meaning the bodily preservation of our
being so the body serves a final end
will and reason direct us hopefully
towards that final end and it's not that
of the body in considering the second
are
he makes he specifies this a little bit
more he says granted that the end of a
person's will and reason be the
preservation of their being it could not
be said that the end of a person is some
good of the body why because our being
consists in soul and body
this is Thomas Aquinas is hilum morphism
the soul informs the body he says that
the but the being of the body depends on
the soul but the being of the human soul
does not depend on the out of the body
and he clarifies two relations that the
body and the soul have for each other
the very body is for the soul has
mattered to its form that's one of them
and the instruments for the the man or
the person who puts them into motion
that by their means he may do their work
so he says all of the goods of the body
which are indeed goods like health and
life and strength and other things like
that are ordained or ordered again
already not or to the goods of the soul
as to their end so what we've got here
are two different arguments saying that
listen the final end is something else
the body is a means to that end
actually the soul is kind of a means to
the end as well but the the soul is
closer to to what that final end is and
this is going to end up coming up again
in a different way once we move on to
article 7 so let's look at this more
plausible idea that the good of the soul
is what happiness would consist in and
again we should remind ourselves a
little bit about the history of this
question for ancient philosophers you
know you might think about the the plate
nests and the aristotelian and the
Stoics in particular they thought that
happiness actually did consist in a good
or goods of the soul namely the state of
being virtuous or engaging in virtuous
activity if we
about Aristotle because he makes a point
of that or the you know the
contemplation of the forms or something
along those lines those are states of
the soul for the Platonic Aristotelian
stoic traditions so Thomas is diverging
from them but he's diverging in a way
that pretty much all Christian thinkers
have and he brings up Augustine here in
the on the contrary right once you put a
sort of monotheistic God into the
picture as the Monnaie Churov goodness
itself you can't really locate the the
ultimate good for human being within
their soul but there were a lot of
people who thought that and he provides
some interesting arguments there in the
objections and he says you know these
are not actually very good arguments
let's take a look at the first one some
good of the soul constitutes a person's
happiness why because happiness is a
person's good and goods are threefold
external goods goods of the body Goods
of the soul we eliminate external goods
we eliminate goods of the body therefore
by process of elimination it consists in
goods of the soul not a bad argument so
long as there aren't any other
alternatives as we've seen that there
there can be so Thomas makes a
distinction about ends he says that the
we can make a distinction in terms of
the end in terms of the thing itself
that we desire to attain and the use
lusus enjoyment can is another way of
translating it or the you know the
attainment or possession of that thing
so if we before we get to the ultimate
happiness or anything like that
let's think about a hamburger right
assuming that you enjoy hamburgers or
you know could be if you're a vegan an
ultimate burger or whatever it also does
that you want to have right so you're
you're eating this thing that is the
enjoyment or uses of it right now you
could possess it but of course that's
going to break down after a while
so I don't maybe you freeze-dry it keep
it for eternity and you have in the back
of your mind
I can always have a hamburger when I
want to right okay that is that that's
an end you could pursue that or you
could pursue just the thing itself and
what would be the thing itself you know
it's hard to say in this case maybe it
would be you know thinking about having
the hamburger but in any case when we're
talking about the final end for human
beings the thing that we're all desiring
whether we realize or not as our you
know human happiness
the final Andy says for human beings
can't be the sole or anything belonging
to the soul why they provide some
arguments here one of these has has this
rather metaphysical basis he says the
sole considered in itself is something
existing in potentiality for for example
it becomes knowing actually from being
potentially knowing and actually
virtuous by being potentially virtuous
and assistance potentiality is for the
sake of act as for its fulfillment that
which in itself is in potentiality
cannot be the last end so we can't say
that the soul itself is the last end for
human beings and then he goes on and he
says it can't be anything belonging to
the soul so it can't be we could might
say a sheep or immortality of the soul
he says it can't be the power of the
soul a habit of the soul or an act of
the soul so you know a habit could be
virtue right he goes on he says the good
that is the last end is the perfect good
fulfilling the desire but our appetite
otherwise the will known otherwise known
as the will is for the universal good
any particular good that we have in our
soul like say the courage that I possess
or the generosity that I possess is not
the universal good that the will
actually desires
it's what Thomas calls a particular
and a participating good the goodness
that I have in my soul by having the
habit the habit you know the habit of
the virtue of courage is not having
courage itself or virtue itself right so
he says that can't be our last end
either now it gets really interesting
when we look at the second argument here
he says if we speak of our last end as
to the attainment or possession thereof
or any use whatever of the thing desired
as an end then a human being in respect
to the soul does something of them does
belong to the last end why because as
Thomas tells us we actually attain and
thereby enjoy happiness through the soul
so happiness is not the soul or a thing
of the soul but we attain happiness
through the soul or as he says pet or
animal right we are able to as he's
going to say later on attain to our
merit happiness through what we've done
with our soul and it's as a soul could
possibly connected to the body there's
the whole discussion about that that we
actually enjoy that happiness
so he says consequently we must say that
happiness is something belonging to the
soul but that which constitutes
happiness is something outside of the
soul so this is a very important
distinction what makes us happy is not
our soul itself but the happiness that
we feel the beatitude Oh in Latin in
that blessedness is another way of
translating it is in the soul but only
insofar as it's directed to that last
and and is enjoying that last end so
what he's providing here are arguments
why goods of the body and even Goods of
the soul
can't be happiness itself but you notice
that even the body plays a role in this
insofar as it's connected with the soul
and the soul definitely plays a role in
human happiness
it just isn't human happiness
you